Mohamed Sanu the newest member of the
New England Patriots for a second round
pick guys were one week away from the
trade deadline we've seen several
significant trades just in the past week
or so and this one makes me wonder other
receiver movement will there be a play
for AJ Green Emanuel Sanders is clearly
available in Peter I thought the
Patriots may take a run at him remember
they signed into an offer sheet a few
years ago when he was a restricted free
agent with Pittsburgh but Sinuhe fills
the spot in New England and now Emmanuel
Sanders AJ Green who knows who else may
be out there anyone you feel strongly
about other than Sanders because it
looks like he's going somewhere
anyone else lurking out there that
you're looking at that you think is
going to likely be traded the next week
well I think Denver would really like to
trade Chris Harris jr. if they can get
value for him you hear it all the time
at this time of year they're not gonna
give him away but Mike I think one of
the interesting things is and I wrote
this in my column this week is that
trading is really gone up and up and up
over the last few years and and I think
a lot of it and this year so far there
have been 13 guys who've played in Pro
Bowls who have been traded already and
there's still seven days to go before
the trading deadline and I think what's
happening is that this new crop of
general managers basically says hey
listen I am not afraid of putting my
neck on the line and trading a two for
Mohamed Sanu I mean even though that's a
Belichick move you see these things all
the time
the Rams aren't afraid of trading to
ones to go get Jalen Ramsey and Bill
Polian the Hall of Fame general manager
told me the other day that there is much
less fear and trepidation of doing a
real gutsy move today he thinks that the
the guys in the in the chair of the
general manager right now are more
transactional they have no fear about
about making moves that a generation ago
GM's would say I'm just not going to do
that yeah it's a different sport right
now and you're right it is very
transactional
I think you know as far as front-office
people and teams like that I think
they've evaluated some of these
situations to go okay maybe we'll give
up a little more than we used to in
years past or last decade or whatever it
may be just because of the salary cap
and free agency and the drafts and
everything about it where teams feel a
little bit more comfortable or nuanced
and in building teams you know if they
have to go through the draft okay we
could do that if we got to do it through
a free agency and we lost draft picks
okay we could do it that way as well
I think there's been enough blueprints
out there through the years to where
teams feel more confident and don't
necessarily need all of the assets at
their hand to realize I can still build
build a quality winner whether it's
through draft picks or free agency so
many things go into that calculation
though what do you give up now and you
you you give up you know something in
the future in order to get better in the
present and the Patriots clearly trying
to address the few weaknesses they have
because it's not like they have glaring
weaknesses sideline to sideline they've
got an excellent defense yeah add
Mohamed Sanu you put yourself in
position
to make it even more likely you get the
number one seed and we know if the
Patriots get the number one seed they
got a pretty good chance of being in the
AFC championship game because they've
been in it every year since 2011 I think
Sinuhe just cements that even more
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports